قضيه واحده اعادت فتح 4000 قضيه اخرى
دونالد ترامب الرئيس الذي غادر المنصب ولم
يختفي من المشهد الاعلامي بعد اتهام ترامب
الرئيس وترامب رجل الاعمال جاء دور ترامب
المترشح ليدخل المحاكم القضيه تعود الى
عام 2016 حين اتهمت ممثله اباحيه ترامب
بشراء صمتها خوفا من فضيحه تعكر حملته
الانتخابيه القضيه كانت اقرب الى مجرد
تسويه شخصيه الا ان شهاده صديق سابق جاءت
لتغير مسار التحقيق ميشال كوهين محامي
ترامبي السابق اعترف بانه دفع شخصيا 130
الف دولار لتسويه القضيه من اموال حمله
موكله الانتخابيه ترامب لا يواجه التهمه
للمره الاولى الا انه سيقف هذه المره امام
محكمه نيويورك التي يسيطر عليها مدعي عام
الديمقراطي حتى النخاع القضيه احيت قضايا
سابقه ومعها جدوى رئيس لا تنقصه المشاكل
بعضها تم تصنيفها كتهام جنائيه وتكفي
ادانه واحده لتنسفه طموحاته السياسيه
بايادي مكبله قد يقف اول رئيس امريكي امام
محكمه جنائيه الا ان سمعه رئيس سابق لا
تهم ترامب وانصاره بقدر سمعه مترشح
للانتخابات المقبله
اتهمت ديمقراطيين باستغلال النفوذ لتسييس
القضيه وهي الحجه التي استغلها للاعب
ورقته المفضله المتمثله بدعوه الانصار
للاعتصام انصار الحزب الجمهوري وان لم يعد
ترامب يحظى بالاجماع بينهم الا انهم
اعتبروه نفقا مظلما عبور ترامب منه بسلام
سيقوده الى البيت الابيض من الباب الواسع